welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka a Fiat 500
Batmobile driver and we finally have our
first look at the car every week same
bat-time same bat-channel and we break
down all of the biggest updates on the
Batman and this week there's a lot to
unpack it's been a crazy time to be a
bat fan recently and the first looks and
leaks on the movie are coming thick and
fast giving us more and more of an idea
of what the film will be about every day
throughout this video we'll be breaking
down the first look at the Batmobile
giving our thoughts on it and what could
be happening in the movie there may be
some spoilers here so if you want to go
into the film as blind as possible then
I highly suggest that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the child to
never miss a video
and without the way let's get into a
breakdown of the bama okay so the
Batmobile was created by designer ash
Thorp who over the last couple of months
has been putting concept cars on his
Instagram page as well as things that
he's pulled from in order to create the
look it was stated that the car was
going to be more in line with his sports
and muscle car and this definitely fits
the aesthetic of that and yes it does
still come in black it looks like chicks
will dig the car as the Internet is
currently blowing up with people getting
very excited over it as we've said
before the Batman is going for a very
grounded and believable feel and this is
definitely showcased here if you'll sort
of like a car from year 1 or Batman
earth 1 which I'll talk about in just a
bit the entire groundedness of the movie
was cemented with the bat bike that was
shown recently as this looked like
something that you could buy in real
life if you had a billionaires bank
account and didn't mind souping up your
moped I'm not sure if this is just me
jumping to assumptions but I have a
feeling that throughout the movie Batman
will be upgrading his arsenal there were
leaks recently that said there would be
a second bat suit in the film and we
also saw Bruce riding a bike in the
first set of leaks and this was then
upgraded to the bat bike the Batmobile
itself too has this grounded feel and
does look like something that if he had
the resources and technology wouldn't be
outside of the realms of possibility so
it does seem like something that the
character could upgrade over time and
add things to Batman is a character that
is constantly improving his tech and as
this is a year 2 story it does make
sense that he would still
be in the stages of just starting out
this is mirrored in the Batsuit - which
has a feeling that it's being put
together by someone rather than made by
a team of designers the Batmobile though
we don't know when will now definitely
be appearing in the film and I think
it's more just a case of when it shows
up now rather than if the car is very
sleek and it looks completely believable
as a real one as well Batman is just
starting out and therefore it's a very
year 1s vehicle and not upgraded to the
level that we would expect I don't even
think it has any weapons attached to it
and the glass is transparent meaning
that you can clearly see through it and
see who's riding it it does look like
it's built purely for speed and this is
exemplified by the engine on the back
that makes it seem like it's one purpose
is to drive fast we have seen Batman
cruising the streets on his bike so I
can imagine that he is using this mainly
to evade police rather than to have in a
modder in which he can take down bad
guys with yesterday we dropped a leak in
which we talked about how the film would
be very similar to earth 1 and Batman is
in the planning stages in that book of
building a car very similar to this
overall I'm really hyped with the car
and I think it looks incredible
stylistically it's very down-to-earth
and now I have a feeling that I will be
getting upgraded throughout the
franchise it does set a really good
foundation of where things could go
anyway that's everything since the last
update yesterday and I'm very excited
for the movie make sure you check out
that video as we go over a lot of the
leaks and where the film pulls from we
do breakdowns on the Batman every week
same bat-time same bat-channel so make
sure you stay luck to never miss any of
the information if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and if you want to support the channel
from as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below you
get access to content early and can also
suggest video topics and breakdowns we
massively appreciate it and it goes a
long way to helping videos like this get
made you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon also just want to let you know
we're giving away a free copy of the
Infinity Saga box set and all you have
to do to be in with a chance of winning
is like the video make sure you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts and the Batmobile in the
comments section below the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of March
and the Celt be shipped out from the in
Tova gets the prize it's the best of
luck to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition that you've been
the best now see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]